bienvenue pour ce nouveau journal sur
TVfil 78 l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale et en sombredi 23 janvier il sort
la question de ses nouvelles frontières
de l'intercommunalité de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les derniers
arbitrages viennent de se faire à quoi
ressemblera l'agglomération au 1er
janvier 2016 un élan courtois pour
défendre la France lors de la Coupe du
monde de la photographie Frédéric
grassera tout à l'heure en plateau la
compétition se déroulera à Montpellier
en avril et puis comme chaque fin de
semaine ce qu'il faut retenir de
l'actualité locale depuis lundi campagne
pour les élections départementales
mesure de sécurité et mesure dans
l'éducation nationale suite aux
attentats
le préfet de région avait lancé un pavé
dans la mare cet été en proposant une
intercommunalité à 800 000 habitants
regroupant des agglomérations des
Yvelines et de l'Essonne depuis les élus
ont proposé un contrat amendement il a
été adopté ce jeudi il redéfinit les
territoires d'intercommunalité au 1er
janvier 2016 Versailles Grand Parc va
accueillir la commune de Vélizy et
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines 5 communes
supplémentaires Catherine zulator
cette commune compose l'agglomération 50
innoise au 1er janvier 2016 il faudra
compter sur cinq villes supplémentaires
plaisir Les Clayes-sous-Bois Villepreux
mourent pas et Coignières ce jeudi 22
janvier la CRC la commission régionale
de coopération intercommunale a adopter
l'amendement présenté par le président
de l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin le
président de Versailles Grand Parc le
président du conseil général et les
présidents de la CAPS et d'europeyson
depuis le mois d'août dernier date à
laquelle le préfet de région a présenté
son schéma nous étions sur la menace
d'une intercommunalité à 800 000
habitants 57 communes donc c'est une
belle victoire et qui nous permet et
bien de pouvoir rester dans une
interconnalité qui sera à taille humaine
avec toujours de la proximité rien n'est
encore officiellement acté mais il faut
dès à présent penser à travailler
ensemble il va falloir se mettre autour
d'une table travailler bien sûr sur
l'intégration de ces communes parce que
celles qui vont
arriver devront se mettre au niveau des
communes qui existent déjà sur notre
territoire donc là tout le travail
commence on n'est pas encore au bout de
nos peines tous les travails de
l'intégration tout le travail aussi de
répartition des compétences et puis
surtout l'impact que ça va voir sur nos
budgets quand on dit nos budgets le
budget de la communauté d'agglomération
et le budget des communes qui vont y
faire leur apparition puis on parlera
aussi de la gouvernance notre but n'est
pas et on est en accord avec Monsieur
logier le président de la casqui et pas
de nous fondre dans la Castille ce que
l'on veut c'est de retravailler ensemble
pour pouvoir justement avoir une
réflexion par rapport aux compétences et
voir dans quelle mesure on peut remettre
à plat les compétences aujourd'hui qui
sont celles de la kesky c'est peut-être
une opportunité aussi pour eux de revoir
les choses de façon différente
l'amendement a été adopté par 69 voix
sur 71 deux voies d'abstention dont
celle du maire de Magny-les-Hameaux
Bertrand Houillon membre de la CRCI
le Saint-Quentin historique de 50 ans de
60-70 et qui
peut être considéré comme intéressant en
termes de bassin de vie encore que
encore que ambassin de vie il faut qu'on
s'interroge de Mani les hameaux jusqu'à
Maurepas par exemple je m'attache plutôt
à une
un travail sur un projet de territoire
et c'était la base de 50 ans de Yvelines
en tant que nouvelle à l'époque et c'est
la base justement du projet avec
l'opération d'intérêt nationale qui est
finalement une continuité de la vie
nouvelle de 50 ans en Yvelines et ce
travail sur ce projet de
territoire semble du plateau de Saclay
le préfet de région doit encore valider
le nouveau périmètre ainsi défini mais à
moins d'un contrat amendement ce qui
semble peu probable tout devrait être
arrêté à la fin du mois de décembre le
délai est court certains élus voudraient
maintenant faire du lobbying auprès des
parlementaires pour obtenir un report
et que pensez-vous de cette
élargissement de 50 ans en Yvelines
assez nouvelles comme une supplémentaire
c'est notre question du jour
micro-trottoir
au niveau budget ça risque de changer
beaucoup de choses parce que évidemment
les communes ont tous un petit budget et
là ça risque
d'éclater il y a déjà beaucoup
d'échanges avec ces communes là je pense
le seul problème c'est qu'il faut que ça
supprime si vous voulez des structures
qui en double si il y a une bonne
répartition des charges voilà que chaque
commune participe
il y en a trop il y a pas besoin de tout
ça parce que moi je le vois je suis une
manière un mot quand tout ça ça a été
rattaché on voit les impôts qui
augmentent qui augmentent qui augmentent
pour qui ne participent pas toujours au
même commune et nous en parlerons la
semaine prochaine de cette élargissement
de la communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce sera au
cours du 7 8 politique mardi à partir de
18h30 en direct il est question à
présent du Mondial de la photographie
dans ce journal Coupe du monde de la
photographie 2015 remise des prix à
Montpellier les 12 13 14 avril et parmi
les compétiteurs français on est long
courtois Frédéric gras bonjour et
bienvenue plus précisément vous êtes
qualifié aux côtés de 17 de vos
confrères comment ça se passe mondial de
la photographie cette compétition en
fait il y a eu une première sélection
pour composer l'équipe les en fait c'est
pas les photographes qui ont été choisis
mais ce sont les images
et en fait
ils ont il y a un prieuré qui donc au
niveau du Groupement National de la
photographie professionnelle qui a
sélectionné parmi toutes les images
présentées en concours
celle qui avait un potentiel pour
éventuellement
représenter la France à ce niveau là et
pourquoi pas après comme l'année
dernière notre collègue Bruno mayor des
crochets de médailles donc là il y a
cette sélection cette présélection et
encore une autre étape à franchir avant
cette cette finale et le choix
définitifs à Montpellier oui là c'est le
2 février en fait donc le du 15 décembre
au 15 janvier 15 juge internationaux
jugé l'intégralité des images et le 2
février à Nashville aux États-Unis sont
annoncés les 10 photos qualifiées par
catégorie alors on va tout de suite
préciser que cette photo qui a été
qualifiée vous ne la verrez pas parce
que ça fait partie des dispositions de
modalités du règlement il est interdit
de la dévoiler tout simplement en
revanche on va quand même préciser que
c'est pas vous qui avez fait la démarche
en fait c'est juste parce que comme vous
avez déjà reçu un prix pour certains de
vos clichés ces clichés là ont été ce
cliché là en l'occurrence a été
sélectionné c'est ça exactement
potentiellement vous n'êtes pas présenté
pour obtenir ce prix en fait non
absolument pas c'est une bonne surprise
voilà exactement oui oui tout à fait
comment ça se passe justement un
courrier on se dit
j'ai été prévenu par le vice-président
de la fédération européenne de
photographie qui est un français déjà
Félix bernettel qui ne m'a appelé au
téléphone mercredi soir pour m'annoncer
la nouvelle et ensuite on a reçu
effectivement
un courrier pour officialiser la chose
donc c'est plutôt effectivement la bonne
nouvelle que vous avez pu découvrir mais
là on est dans le cadre d'un Mondial de
la photographie donc il y a plusieurs
pays qui participent qu'est-ce qui te
différencie la photographie française du
reste du monde il y a une différence oui
alors il y a on voit vraiment des
différences d'un entre chaque pays tout
le monde n'a pas la même approche
exactement et c'est très intéressant
justement d'aller sur le site internet
où les images l'année dernière ont été
publiées de de pour les pour les clients
qui ont fait les photographes pardon qui
ont soit eu un prix soit on était dans
les 10 finalistes parce que justement on
voit bien que d'un pays l'autre on n'a
pas du tout la même approche ni dans le
portrait ni dans les autres catégories
puisqu'en fait il y en a 6 et moi par
exemple j'ai la catégorie illustration
d'accord donc illustration portrait
mariage
paysage et j'en oublie deux super vous
reviennent mais en tout cas qu'est-ce
qui explique cette approche c'est
culturel en fait on n'a pas le même
rapport au sujet aussi qu'on va
photographier
oui puis il y a peut-être aussi donc
comme vous le dites l'approche
culturelle mais aussi les techniques
utilisées c'est à dire par exemple aux
États-Unis certaines photos sont très
très retouchées en France c'est moins
dans notre culture on retouche les
images mais c'est quand même plus
naturel donc voilà après je sais pas
trop pourquoi il y a des différences
comme ça entre enfin vraiment des
différences vraiment significatives
entre les pays et le travail se fait
uniquement sur du numérique l'argentique
est complètement oublié dans la
compétition déjà c'est obligé d'envoyer
un fichier numérique de même si ça a été
fait même si ça a été fait un argentique
ce qui est possible dans tous les cas il
faut numériser le fichier le négatif et
l'envoyer pour le jugement en numérique
ça c'était pour la pour la parenthèse
mal alors on en revient à cette
compétition quels sont vos atouts alors
au milieu des autres français aussi
vous pensez vous différencier sur quoi
mon image est poétique voilà et elle
représente bien la France quand vous la
découvrirez vous comprendrez pourquoi je
dis ça et le elle il y a des des points
d'allumage qui qui permet de dire ça a
été fait en France quand vous dites ces
poétique c'est ce que vous essayez
d'insuffler chaque fois quel que soit le
thème de la photographie pas uniquement
celle qui a été sélectionnée mais
au-delà de ça dans votre travail mais
j'essaie honnêtement de
moi dans ma tête et dans mon univers je
différencie mon travail personnel ce qui
est le cas pour cette image là du
travail que je fais avec mes clients
parce que souvent avec les clients on a
la contrainte du temps malheureusement
l'image qui est sélectionnée entre la
retouche et la prise de vue c'est 7 ou 8
heures de travail donc ça serait un
vendable où je peux pas faire ça avec
des clients et et second de choses c'est
que
les clients ne viennent pas pour ça non
plus ils ont envie d'avoir plusieurs
images de leur famille ou de leurs
enfants là je peux pas dévoiler mais les
personnes qui sont sur cette image là il
y a eu une seule photo quoi voilà il
faut que ce travail qui se concentre sur
une seule photo vous avez le temps de
faire de la photo justement pour votre
plaisir là du travail et des concours et
encore alors déjà moi les concours ce
n'est que du plaisir c'est à dire que je
ne fais je fais ça uniquement parce que
j'adore la compétition
alors là c'est vraiment pas de la
contrainte et ensuite oui je fais de la
photo plaisir notamment ma petite fille
qui le Père Noël lui a amené un bel
appareil photo parce qu'en fait elle m'a
harcelé elle a même son blog maintenant
et on s'amuse bien quoi sur les traces
de papa voilà un petit peu on verra vous
dites la compétition ça vous apporte
quelque chose aussi d'un point de vue
professionnel pour le pour les clients
aussi c'est un plus pour les clients
parce que il vous découvre autrement ou
ça vous permet aussi vous d'enrichir vos
techniques vos approches photographiques
en fait c'est un ensemble il y a plein
de choses déjà un moi j'adore me mesurer
aux autres des fois on gagne des fois on
perds voilà exactement
petit 2 ça permet de d'aller dans des
voies ou justement avec nos clients on
pourrait pas spécialement aller donc
justement s'améliorer continuer à
progresser être face à des
problématiques qu'on ne rencontre pas
spécialement avec nos clients et puis
ensuite il faut pas se le cacher non
plus je suis sur le plateau c'est aussi
ça permet aussi de faire parler de soi
et de se rappeler qu'on est qu'on existe
toujours et que voilà on essaie d'aller
mettre de l'avant et en dehors de cette
Coupe du Monde vous allez aussi relancer
cette année cette opération avec le
Secours populaire séance photo
professionnelle en studio en échange des
dons qui seront ensuite apportées aux
enfants défavorisés comment fonctionne
cette opération c'est la quatrième
édition la quatrième édition toujours
avec le Secours populaire l'année
dernière on avait changé et puis on est
revenu avec le Secours populaire cette
année
donc en fait actuellement les personnes
qui sont intéressées peuvent s'inscrire
les inscriptions d'ailleurs ont déjà
commencé
et et au lieu de payer les 85 euros de
la séance il donne des dons sur des
couches soit de la nourriture etc et
l'intégralité des produits une fois
l'opération terminée et reversée au
Secours populaire de ma ville puisque
chaque photo graphe en tout cas en
France voilà et donc moi ma ville c'est
Élancourt donc c'est reversé au Secours
populaire d'Élancourt c'est limité le
nombre de places juste pour savoir si
les gens veulent s'inscrire on va revoir
la fiche avec les informations pratiques
alors non c'est pas limité en fait ce
qui limitant c'est les créneaux horaires
et les disponibilités de chacun donc
c'est plus ça sinon non c'est pas limité
il reste encore de la place il y a aucun
souci je reçois des demandes
quotidiennement j'en ai encore reçu une
là quand j'attendais et j'ai vu que ce
matin vos confrères du Parisien nous ont
fait aussi un petit article donc
forcément vous avec le passage télé le
bouche à oreille donc il y a de la place
que ce soit chez moi que ce soit chez ma
collègue Marie-Louise aussi qui a
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine même si moi je
suis booké et ben ils peuvent aller chez
ma collègue le but c'est de ramener le
plus de produits pour tous ces enfants
qui malheureusement n'ont pas la même
chose que les nôtres voilà le Secours
populaire et les autres années ça a bien
fonctionné justement quel bilan peut
faire alors ça a toujours bien
fonctionné il a une dernière il y avait
eu une petite baisse mais en l'année
dernière on n'avait pas demandé de l'eau
en fait et on pense que c'est venu de là
mais sinon tous les retours on sont
toujours positifs etc voilà cette
opération de solidarité qui se déroule
en ce moment notamment auprès de vous
Frédéric graff photographe surélon court
et puis il y a cette Coupe du monde de
la photographie on verra si en février
vous passez cette présélection avant
ensuite d'avoir le verdict final ce sera
en avril vous vous tendons bien sûr
informé merci et d'être venu sur ce
plateau pour nous en parler on continue
ce journal on va passer à l'essentiel de
la semaine à présent
on subit la population subit une
austérité
importante grandissante et l'ensemble de
ces parties ont appelé à une
manifestation le 15 novembre pour une
alternative à l'austérité et donc suite
à ce rassemblement nous avons décidé de
nous rassembler également au niveau
départemental sur le canton de Saint-Cyr
aujourd'hui on doit comment dire
redonner de de l'espoir dans une vie
meilleure pour les populations du canton
et de et au niveau national et que le
Parti socialiste au niveau national ou
même d'ailleurs dans les dans le dans le
canton on n'a pas fait la preuve de
cet espoir qu'il a promis mais qu'il n'a
pas tenu et donc en décrétant cette
politique d'austérité depuis l'élection
de 2012 on voit bien qu'au contraire il
bloque il
commentaires les sports de tout le monde
et je pense que c'est aussi en partie
pour ça que l'on voit cette montée du
Front national toujours à propos des
départementales Nicolas Dupont-Aignan
qui a rebapté sa formation debout la
France est venue dans les Yvelines jeudi
soir afin de soutenir ces candidats
parmi eux Thomas Garo 28 ans il se
présente sur le canton de
montigny-le-bretonneux-guy en cours il
est aussi le porte-parole local du
mouvement
on sera présent dans plus de la moitié
des cantons
c'est difficile d'être présent partout
notamment pour un parti qui est jeune
comme debout la France
faut dire aussi que la réforme qui a été
faite pour ces élections et faites pour
ça elle est faite pour faire en sorte
qu'il y a que les gros parties qui
puissent se présenter partout mais on va
essayer de se présenter dans un maximum
de cantons avec des gens compétents et
motivés non handicap principal c'est la
formation des binômes c'est pour ça
cette réforme qui maintenant met en
place des binômes qui vont devoir siéger
il y aura deux candidats sur chacun des
cantons même 4 avec les supplays ça et
le découpage des cantons aussi alors le
fait de faire des binômes en soi c'est
pas très compliqué d'appliquer la parité
de toute façon nous c'est pas un
problème vraiment qu'on a debout la
France au législatif de 2012 on était le
seul parti qui avait le plus de femmes
que d'hommes sur nos listes d'ailleurs
été condamnés à cause de ça mais sinon
non c'est le fait de pouvoir présenter
partout dans tous les cantons c'est
assez difficile mais on va essayer
d'être présent dans le maximum mais on
n'est pas non plus obligé de s'enfermer
dans ce choix de mort qui est de devoir
choisir systématiquement entre le Front
national ou le PS et l'UMP espèce de
triangle des Bermudes on a le droit à
d'autres tu dois les Français ont le
droit à d'autres choix et en proposant
cette voix Nicolas Dupont-Aignan debout
la France propose le rassemblement le
clivage gauche droite à plus vraiment de
sens de nos jours quand le Parti
socialiste fait le programme que l'UMP
aurait souhaité faire quand le Front
national nous propose le programme
économique du Parti communiste des
années 60 le clivage gauche droite a
plus vraiment de sens donc le parti
debout la France c'est un parti
républicain qui est veut défendre un
patriotisme serein et qui est dans une
idée économiquement on est sur l'idée de
l'État stratège dans le reste de
l'actualité de
la les sites de la communauté juive qui
font maintenant l'objet d'une
surveillance à rapprocher de la part des
militaires exemples de vent de la
synagogue de Versailles le préfet qui
est d'ailleurs rendu en personne
des militaires du 152e régiment
d'infanterie de Colmar en faction devant
la synagogue de Versailles c'était ce
samedi matin et depuis ce week-end ce
sont en tout on sites principaux de la
communauté juive dans le département qui
font l'objet d'une surveillance
particulière de la part de l'armée
crèche école et lieu de culte le préfet
a d'ailleurs rencontré Samuel Sandler le
président de la communauté versaillesse
pour expliquer le dispositif et rassuré
sur chacun des sites il y a une équipe
de 12 militaires qui se relaient pour
assurer une permanence H24 et pour
protéger la communauté rassurer la
communauté notre objectif c'est de dire
à la communauté qu'on est bien sûr avec
elle dans ces moments difficiles et
douloureux et qu'on lui donne les moyens
de sa sécurité vous savez que les
attentats ont ciblé fortement à la
communauté juive au moment notamment de
très grave très grave action de l'hyper
cacher à Paris donc la communauté juive
se sent vraiment
meurtries les 11 lieux faisant l'objet
d'une surveillance particulière se situe
notamment à Versailles mais aussi comme
ici à Maurepas d'autres villes sont
concernées poignées la forêt et un peu
plus loin Poissy ça retrouve encore
Saint-Germain-en-Laye ce mardi le préfet
des Yvelines rassemblera tous les chefs
d'équipe afin de faire le point sur le
dispositif et présenter une feuille de
route il sera aussi question de
l'organisation des rapports entre
militaires police nationale et police
municipale le plan Vigipirate alerte
attentat mobilise 10000 militaires en
France 6000 rien que sur l'Île-de-France
et 132 dans les Yvelines
et c'est ce mercredi à l'issue du
conseil des ministres que Manuel Valls
annoncé une série de mesures pour
renforcer la lutte contre le terrorisme
2680 emplois supplémentaires créés au
cours des trois prochaines années au
sujet de la radicalisation en prison 60
aumôniers supplémentaires vont être
recrutés le Premier ministre a aussi
annoncé la création de cinq quartiers
dédiés au regroupement des personnes
détenu radicalisées sur le modèle d'une
expérimentation qui menée actuellement à
la prison de Fresnes je vous propose
d'écouter ce qu'en pense Cédric Thorez
il est le responsable du syndicat
Ufap UNSA justice dans les Yvelines il
est également surveillant pénitentiaire
à Bois-d'Arcy
le problème c'est incarcéré des détenus
des détenus par exemple ça se passe à
Fresnes ils sont 20 ils sont une
vingtaine je crois à Fresnes ça se passe
bien mais parce qu'ils sont plus une
vingtaine
mais demain vous avez on parle de
centaines voire de milliers de jeunes
qui sont partis faire le diode en Syrie
ou en Irak on les met où clairement on
les met où
à pouvoir ou alors il va falloir créer
des établissements mais c'est pareil
alors là on va sur le système Guantanamo
est-ce que c'est la bonne solution je
sais pas ça veut dire que on les met on
les enferme et puis on jette la clé
c'est peut-être pas la bonne idée c'est
peut-être se poser la question en amont
ceux qui sont déjà radicalisés
on s'en occupe mais il faut peut-être
prévenir
mais ça c'est pas c'est pas le boulot de
la prison c'est le boulot du
gouvernement de prendre des bonnes
décisions et une bonne fois pour toute
de prendre des décisions il faut
recruter des imams aussi il faut traiter
des amis musulmans parce que eux sont
importants aujourd'hui alors il y a des
choses sur lesquelles il faudra mettre
des règles mais il faut que ils sont
recruter parce que on a besoin de plus
de plus plus de personnes qui sont qui
sont tolérants et la plupart des
musulmans qui sont en prison ne sont pas
radicaux au contraire même certains ont
certainement dénoncé mais dans les faits
de masse de ceux qui voulaient
stigmatiser la République en disant
c'est votre faute si on est en prison
ils sont pas ils se sont pas manifestés
puis bon c'est très difficile d'avoir un
discours comme ça transport maintenant
et travaux surtout avec le chantier
d'aménagement de la RD30 à hauteur de
plaisir qui débutent les voix seront
doublées une réunion d'information vient
de se tenir cette semaine
cette route c'est le matin c'est
infernal quoi on va vous allez mettre 10
minutes alors que en temps normal vous
mettez 3 minutes pour atteindre la
nationale la RD30 a longtemps été le
calvaire de cette habitante de plaisir
et de bien d'autres saturé engorger
bouchonner les termes pour la décrire le
manque pas en ce début d'année le
chantier d'aménagement et
d'élargissement de cette route à
commencer un projet attendu depuis 20
ans c'est impératif que ces travaux
démarrent et on en est vraiment très
heureux parce que et bien on va se
rendre compte que il va y avoir une
fluidité une sécurité qui va être
beaucoup plus grande et certains
plaisirs s'inquiètent qu'il y ait encore
plus de circulation et de toute façon la
circulation est là donc aujourd'hui
plutôt que d'avoir des voitures qui
stagne qui qui bouchonnent au niveau de
la pollution c'est bien pire que des
voitures qui passent en fluidité et qui
ne font que traverser
les voix seront doublées entre la RN12
au sud et le rond-point du petit
Saint-Cloud au nord au niveau de cette
deux fois de voix les giratoire du petit
Saint-Cloud et de Jules Régnier seront
dénivelés tout comme ceux du pressoir et
des Gatines qui seront heureux groupés
en un seul rond-point des passerelles
piétons cyclistes sont également au
programme ces aménagements permettront
aussi de décongestionner le centre-ville
de plaisir vers lequel les
automobilistes se reportaient souvent la
circulation de plaisir c'était quand
même un peu engorgée surtout sur le
centre-ville et c'est très bien il
fallait venir
riveraine de la RD30 Christine elle
s'inquiète des nuisances sonores moi je
suis pas du tout gênée par par le bruit
donc ça c'est clair mais une fois
qu'elle passera à deux fois de voir
quand sera-t-il parce qu'aujourd'hui il
y a quand même les bois qui nous
protègent mais après donc c'est pour ça
que je suis nue aujourd'hui pour avoir
beaucoup plus d'informations sur le sur
le sujet un sujet bien sûr abordé lors
de cette réunion publique et auquel la
mère a répondu en ce qui concerne les
nuisances sonores il va y avoir des murs
en train de bruit qui sont prévus et
puis les calculs au niveau des décibels
ont été faits pour qu'on soit vraiment
en dessous même de la norme actuelle la
promesse a été faite hier les deux sens
de circulation seront maintenus pendant
toute la durée des travaux coût de
l'opération environ 78 millions d'euros
financés par le conseil général et la
région fin des travaux prévus à l'été
excellent week-end c'est la fin donc de
cette édition je vous retrouve lundi en
direct à 18h pour une semaine nouvelle
semaine d'information locale